corona deutschland winterfest machen das
hat der künftige kanzler scholz
versprochen das war allerdings schon vor
einigen wochen passiert ist das aber
noch nicht deutschland ist ja offenbar
noch nicht corona winterfest deshalb
heute also wieder corona gipfel alle
mussten ran alte regierung neue
regierung und obendrauf den
ministerpräsidenten und was dabei
rausgekommen ist oder auch nicht das
besprechen wir jetzt mit unserem bild
politik chef jan schäfer hier bei uns im
team herrscht also was rausgekommen oder
was ist nicht rausgekommen also wir
haben heute eine neue ära gesehen das
virus ist immer noch da aber es gab
heute einen stabwechsel eingeleitet von
der bundeskanzlerin der noch
bundeskanzlerin muss man sagen angela
merkel hat in die bei diesem corona
gipfel der in einem etwas 9-format
stattgefunden hat den stab quasi an
ihren nachfolger übergeben olaf scholz
und so hat olaf scholz mehr oder weniger
auch durch diese gut drei stunden
hindurch geführt am ende wurde nichts
richtig beschlossen aber es gibt doch
dinge die angegangen werden sollen so
hat es auch in dieser sitzung formuliert
und es wird einen neuen corona gipfel
geben nämlich diese woche diesen
donnerstag und da wird es dann konkrete
ergebnisse wir geben aber man hat sich
schon auf einen zielpfad geeinigt warum
jetzt erst der zufahrt warum wartet man
jetzt wieder zwei tage also es ist sehr
wichtig olaf scholz war es zumindest
wichtig um das ist herausgekommen aus
den gesprächen noch mal ein bisschen
zeit zu haben zumindest zu diskutieren
es gibt ein paar punkte über die wir
vielleicht einfach mal ganz kurz reden
könnten die sind auch durchaus heikel
auch für die ampel parteien das muss man
ganz klar sagen da ist beispielsweise
das thema allgemeine impfpflicht etwas
was mittlerweile auch offenbar in der
spd-spitze gewollt wird christian
lindner die fdp hat er bisher ja noch
probleme gehabt es geht auch um die
frage ob man das infektionsschutzgesetz
noch mein nachbessert also die frage ist
es auch über den 15 dezember hinaus
beispielsweise möglich ein lock down in
den ländern zu verhängen und die frage
natürlich wann läuft eigentlich der
allgemeine impfstatus ab da ist jetzt
auch zu hören gewesen heute aus der
runde dass man sagt also deutlich
weniger als neun monate möglicherweise
ist nach sechs monaten impfung dann der
impfstatus schon abgelaufen das wäre ein
richtiger hammer aber ich werde da sind
noch 1000 fragezeichen fragen haben wir
ja alle genug offenbar
die ministerpräsidenten und die
künftigen regierungsmitglieder all diese
fragezeichen selber noch in den augen
und in den köpfen aber bleiben wir bei
diesem im status das ist doch das was
jetzt den alltag der deutschen
beschäftigt wir sehen überall zweig wir
wissen im moment noch ganz klar wer
draußen bleiben muss nämlich die die
sich noch gar nicht haben impfen lassen
die noch gar nicht als geimpft gelten
aber das könnte künftig auch uns
wiedertreffen jan das ist da schon
besprochen worden heute in der runde
richtig und es gibt auch da wieder ein
vorstoß des künftigen bundeskanzlers
wenn dann alles so kommt das ist der
zweig im einzelhandel geben soll und
zwar generell flächendeckend zweig ob da
die supermärkte ausgenommen sind das ist
noch nicht ganz klar das wird man dann
zum donnerstag hin sicherlich dann
festzurren aber zweig im einzelhandel
bedeuten dass alle die nicht geimpft
sind dann nicht mehr einkaufen gehen
können und das ist so ein bisschen etwas
gewesen was viele ministerpräsident
heute auch gesehen haben oder scholz
auch als zusätzliches als sich druck
moment auf die ungeimpften zu sagen okay
wir müssen uns jetzt noch impfen lassen
wie einig war man sich denn heute
eigentlich wie war die stimmung gab es
da viel stress gab es viel streit oder
war es doch eher harmonisch also das was
wir gehört haben war die stimmung
insgesamt gar nicht so schlecht es gab
aber zwei ministerpräsidenten die immer
wieder auch ein bundesland
beispielsweise gefordert haben das sind
die die im süden sitzen einmal markus
söder ganz klar in bayern da gibt es
auch aussagen von anderen
spd-ministerpräsidenten die uns
zugetragen wurden nach dem motto ja also
das nervt langsam dass der bayer immer
mit seiner bundes mit seinem bundesland
kommt und dann natürlich sachsens
ministerpräsident michael kretschmer wir
haben aber auch gehört vom grünen
ministerpräsidenten aus
baden-württemberg winfried kretschmann
dass er eigentlich in der runde die
heutige tag hat gerne zu ergebnissen
gekommen wäre die hat es noch nicht
gegeben er muss sich zwei tage weiter
gedulden bis donnerstags kapiert man als
bürger 1 nicht die sagen uns dauernd es
ist fünf nach zwölf dann ist ein paar
tage später als 1200 sich es halb eins
also es drängt es pressiert es hat
einfach alles keine zeit mehr aber
beschlüsse gibt es auf diesem gipfel
nicht vor zwei wochen nicht jetzt heute
telefoniert man und video schaltet man
wieder zusammen und jetzt sagt man ja
machen wir am donnerstag noch mal und
beschließen wollen wir immer noch nix
also vor zwei wochen gab es oder vor
knapp zwei wochen muss man ja sagen es
war dann der donnerstag vor jetzt zwölf
tagen und in zwei tagen ist es dann
genau zwei wochen her da gab es
natürlich schon beschlüsse und hier
sollen nicht ausgereicht haben vielen
haben sie nicht ausgereicht das ist
richtig an anderen waren sie sogar zum
teil zu weit gehen ganz klar aber
offenbar hat die infektions lage auch
wenn wir in die krankenhäuser schauen
viele es doch noch mal wieder überholt
und man ist zu dem ergebnis gekommen
auch gerade olaf scholz als künftiger
chef der ampel dass es dinge gibt die
nachgebessert werden müssen deswegen
noch mal der gipfel am donnerstag und da
bis dahin gibt es einen gewissen
diskussionsprozess was wir heute
festgestellt haben ist auf jeden fall
dass olaf scholz anders ran geht er
moderiert das ganze etwas anders also es
war nicht so konfrontativ zumindest ist
es das was wir hören bis auf diejenigen
die ich gerade genannt hatte markus
söder und michael kretschmer die auf
deutlich härtere maßnahmen und auch
beschlüsse gedrungen haben mit
parteipolitik steckt denn da jetzt auch
in diesem takt das jetzt vielleicht auch
noch mal zwei tage ein bisschen sacken
zu lassen da ist natürlich extrem viel
parteipolitik drin das ist ganz klar
gerade markus söder der ja nun nicht als
kanzlerkandidat antreten konnte dieses
drama was die union erlitten hat
miterlebt hat und gerne doch natürlich
bundeskanzler geworden wäre der sieht
sich als heimlicher künftiger
oppositionsführer
wir wissen in der nächsten woche wird
wenn alles gut geht dann olaf scholz zum
bundeskanzler gewählt dann ist auch die
union offiziell oppositionspartei dann
braucht sie einen klaren
oppositionsführer und markus söder weiß
dass die cdu derzeit noch keinen
richtigen neuen chef hat stößt also
diese lücke er will sich als derjenige
profilieren nicht nur weil er 20 23
selbst eine wahl gewinnen muss sondern
als derjenige starke mann in der union
der jetzt rot gelb grün also der ampel
ordentlich kontra gibt